hola y bienvenidos a todos, esta es
la transmisión de invitados de inferencia activa 28.1, es
el 14 de octubre de 2022.
hoy vamos a escuchar y
discutir la reconcepción de la racionalidad de
Giovanni Rolla, así que Giovanni,
muchas gracias por unirse,
espero con ansias esta presentación y
discusión, así que vamos a  gracias
gracias entonces fue un placer
recibir su invitación hace un par de
meses y estoy encantado de estar aquí
para tener esta oportunidad de hablar sobre mi
trabajo
um me ahorraré su solicitud
um nuestra sugerencia estoy uh presentando
esto  artículo que escribí hace un par de años
y eh, mientras hablábamos entre bastidores
, he cambiado de opinión varias
veces y voy a dejar esto claro
durante la presentación desde que
publiqué ese artículo, pero es un
placer  sin embargo, tener la oportunidad
de presentar este video aquí y
compartirlo con el mundo, así que estoy muy
feliz,
entonces estaremos hablando de
reconcebir la racionalidad y este es el
itinerario.  Estaba pensando en
presentarles, así que primero
hablaré sobre la racionalidad y la
cognición sin contenido, luego presentaré
mi punto de vista, al que llamé
racionalidad radicalmente inactiva y palabras de seguridad
sobre la agencia y la interacción
y el razonamiento competentes y la racionalidad son
una pareja cercana.  de objeciones, la
primera es que
todo lo que estoy presente aquí es un verdadero
liberal de una manera excesivamente liberal que
abarca demasiado y la segunda
objeción que creo que es la que más les
puede interesar es
si es compatible con el efecto.  con un
proceso predictivo en nuestra codificación predictiva que
está, por supuesto, en las instalaciones
cerca de los dos autos en el centro para
hacer una influencia activa,
así que
aquí está lo siento,
mis pensamientos iniciales sobre el asunto es
que tradicionalmente los muy
ortodoxos  tener una opinión sobre la racionalidad,
eh, supone que, según mi
conocimiento, es como una suposición realmente que la
racionalidad debe en su razonamiento
que, por ejemplo,  ance Creo que B en una
acción a son racionales si y solo si
existe el razonamiento que respalda
el Bure y, por supuesto, no es
cualquier razonamiento, la pregunta de razonamiento
debe adquirirse con ciertos
puntos de referencia formales, como la lógica clásica
o el razonamiento de probabilidad o
heurística, por lo que creer y actuar
racionalmente de acuerdo con esta película tradicional
requiere cumplir con ciertos estándares formales
y esto, como dije, me parece en
gran medida una suposición sobre lo que
significa ser racional sobre la definición de la
racionalidad en términos de razonamiento,
por lo que si la racionalidad requiere razonamiento
y  si el razonamiento involucra la evaluación
de creencias frente a ciertos
puntos de referencia formales, entonces la racionalidad implica
contenido para la cognición,
donde considero que el contenido
tiene condiciones mínimas de precisión, puede ser
correcto o incorrecto o está dentro o dentro de una
noción más importante siendo verdadero o falso, por lo que
el  La idea aquí es que la racionalidad
necesariamente implica contenido implica
creencias  el razonamiento y la comparación o
lamento actualizar ahora mismo
una actualización de software. Lamento que haya
una ventana emergente en mi ventana aquí, así
que, esa sería, creo, la
visión estándar sobre la racionalidad
y,
si es así, la racionalidad necesariamente
implica  contenido, encaja bien
con el cognitivismo clásico o el
cognitivismo en general,
que es la opinión de que la combinación
necesariamente implica
contenido representacional al menos para algunos
cognitivistas, por supuesto, podría implicar
también
un contenido conceptual, pero al
menos un contenido representacional que tiene
condiciones de precisión,
pero esta visión clásica no es
tan buena, no encaja tan bien con la
cognición radicalmente inactiva y encarnada en la
que estoy aquí, eh, pensando no
específicamente en el radicalismo y el activismo de
Goodwin Maine en los libros recientes, pero
creo que también desafía a otros  puntos de vista
que no se presentan como radicales y
activos pero, por supuesto, comparten algunos principios
básicos con radicales y activistas.  sm
podríamos llamarlos uh
puntos de vista radicalmente incorporados de las cogniciones como
um con los puntos de vista presentados por Ezekiel
Powell o Berman
sensory model life también tienes
la variedad de inactivismo de Gallagher en su
libro de 2017 y también me refiero a la vista
por Tony kimero en su  Libro de 2009 sobre
psicología ecológica y
sistemas dinámicos, todos comparten inquilinos comunes
y aquí estoy. Sé que esto es muy
controvertido, pero estoy tratando esos
puntos de vista como puntos de vista radicalmente encarnados de la
cognición y, pero estoy específicamente
enfocado en puntos de vista radicales y activos de la
cocina.
todos dicen que el reconocimiento no tiene contenido
representacional, lo cual es
una forma de decir que podemos pensar en
formas básicas de cognición sin contenido
o un nivel básico de
reconocimiento sin contenido
que surge a través de la
exploración activa del entorno de uno y más
allá del activismo radical y por  lo que queremos
decir
esto podría ser que esta idea podría
cobrarse en términos de dominar los compromisos sensoriales motores
, una cuestión de saber  -cómo
el saber cómo relacionarse con su
entorno en lugar de saber que
hay cosas a su alrededor, así que esto
es muy claramente lo que Paulo y sus
colegas y uh kimero, por ejemplo, hacen
en sus libros uh radical y el activismo
tiene una cierta tendencia a sesgarse  Compromisos de
modelos sensoriales Esquemas de modelos sensoriales
Etc.
y uh,
pero creo que los desarrollos recientes han
incorporado que, por lo tanto, este es el
uso de la esencia de esta idea,
así que si combinamos puntos de vista encarnados radicales
de rumiación o radical y activismo
y el combustible clásico en  la racionalidad
lo que tenemos es algo que Angle ha
descrito de la siguiente manera
un activismo es la opinión de que la cognición
se basa en una oración
comprensión racional del mundo que se basa
en la adquisición sensoriomotora de la situación de la
vida real
y explica estos uh esta idea de
pre-  comprensión racional
por
um
por las ideas de melopentin
Heidegger según quien la relación
con el mundo puede ser sólo una raíz en
p  La práctica inactiva en la actuación y la
práctica interna está mediada a través
del cuerpo, por lo que lo que parece estar implícito
aquí es que, a diferencia de la actuación y la práctica, la
racionalidad no es en
realidad algo que no se encuentra en un
nivel muy básico de combinación, por lo que esto es
lo que sucedió cuando nosotros.
hacer espacio para un nivel básico de cognición
enraizado en lo activo y en la práctica y
divorciarlo de los niveles superiores de
combinación que suelen ser el
locus el clásico afortunado de la racionalidad,
por lo que
la idea en resumen es esa
cognición contenciosa o cognición básica
que emerge a través de los sentidos.  los
compromisos motores no son racionales, por
lo que los compromisos sensoriales modernos, sin embargo, las
virtudes en prolíficas que pueden ser no
pueden evaluarse desde el punto de vista de la
racionalidad, solo el contenido para la cognición
, la combinación de alto nivel puede ser una
definición racional que se expresa, por
ejemplo, en creencias y recientemente
y bueno, esto es algo  que
no he tocado en el papel, pero
fue mi motivación implícita para d  lidiar con
este tema
como alguien que proviene de la filosofía de
la mente es la idea del mito de lo
dado al menos una versión de él
me pareció en ese momento y
un crítico me convenció correctamente de no
tocar el tema  fue muy
enrevesado en mi presentación inicial,
pero me parece que si separamos el
reconocimiento básico de un pensamiento
y una acción racionales y no apuntamos hacia
el
pozo, no hay una intersección
entre estos dos niveles, me parece que
radical y activismo y  uh,
puntos de vista similares estarían comprometidos con el mito de
lo dado impopularizado por Sellers y
moderado por McDowell como un problema para
campos imperiosos de mi mente,
por lo que parece que esto es, creo, un
[Música]
un problema filosóficamente interesante,
pero no es algo que es  eh, en la
vanguardia del artículo, mi
motivación implícita aquí fue explicar
cómo podemos combinar el
nivel de cognición sin contenido o básico a través de
compromisos sensoriales modernos con la proporción  nalidad, si
no puede, parece
que hay algo dado que
no se explica completamente en nuestra imagen
de la mente, así que esto es algo que
quería. Todavía quiero intentar explorar
esta intuición con más claridad, pero no lo he hecho.
No
toqué esto,
pero creo que hay algo en la
dirección de qué, por qué, lo
que mostraré hoy es una forma de quitar
esta acusación de estar comprometido
con el mito de lo dado,
entonces, ¿cómo podemos volver a concebir la racionalidad? Quiero
decir  Creo que para evitar ese
problema y evitar la idea de que tenemos
dos niveles completamente separados
entre sí, donde uno El Superior es
el locus de la racionalidad clásica y qué
más hay debajo, no es racional.
Creo que la idea es rechazar la
racionalidad.  debe definirse o
implica necesariamente el razonamiento
no necesita ser todavía concebido pero
entonces el desafío es ofrecer una
propuesta positiva de lo que es la racionalidad sino el
razonamiento y aquí está Susan H  urley en un
artículo que mi conocimiento es el único
que trata
sobre este tema y creo que ella
también estaba preocupada por el mito de lo
dado por cierto en ese momento y él es una
cita larga de aquí phenomide yo
leyéndolo es esa racionalidad  podría
emerger de un sistema complejo de
relaciones jerárquicas centralizadas de
inhibición, facilitación y coordinación
entre diferentes capas horizontales, cada una
de las cuales es una racionalidad dinámica y ambientalmente
situada reconcebida en
términos horizontales o modulares, eh, no
sé si tiene que usar esta
terminología, pero  de todos modos, así es como
eligió expresarlo está
relacionado de manera sostenible con el medio ambiente, no
depende solo de los procedimientos internos que
median entre la entrada y la salida, como el
contenido, ya sea para el organismo como un
todo o para un
módulo cognitivo central delimitado verticalmente, sino que
depende de  relaciones complejas entre
mundo dedicado que involucra capas que
monitorean y responden a aspectos específicos
de la n  entorno natural y social
y de la red neuronal y reducen
la retroalimentación de sus
respuestas. Que yo sepa, este es el primer caso de
alguien que trabaja en el enfoque inactivo.
en un enfoque diferente del radical y el
activismo y aquí está el más antiguo
y, según mi conocimiento, antes de escribir ese
artículo es que la propuesta más clara
de racionalidad reconcebida
en los términos nativos, pero no es
algo que ganó fuerza
después de su publicación para  mi conocimiento en
realidad no he visto mucho desde entonces
y para resumir la idea es que
tenemos que cambiar el Foco explicativo
que es la racionalidad no se
piensa exclusivamente como un Contenido que implica
capacidad en esta propuesta se sitúa
o Mundo implicado en mundos aumentados
y si se encarna radicalmente,
depende de la morfología y la acción corporales
y de cómo se sitúa y actúa el organismo.
s en ese entorno, la idea
estará mínimamente muerta, así que esto es lo que llamo
racionalidad radicalmente inactiva
es, eh, en una
definición muy vaga, hasta ahora es que un asiático
actúa racionalmente en la medida en que el ser humano
mantiene una interacción competente con
su entorno coordinando sus
habilidades cognitivas  de acuerdo con
las condiciones ambientales de restricciones
y estaciones sólidas y, por supuesto, esto a
veces requiere adaptarse a
circunstancias imprevistas. La
intuición central es esta
y es interesante comparar esta
idea de racionalidad radical y activa
con otra de las ideas de Susan Hurley en
un texto de 2003.  ella dice
razones eh para actuar que argumenta
que las razones para actuar pueden estar
limitadas por el contexto donde argumenta en contra de la
restricción de generalidad de eh Gareth Evans
y esta es la defensa de la idea de
islas de racionalidad práctica,
por lo que todavía trata la racionalidad como
algo esencialmente que se relaciona  al
razonamiento aquí, pero este tipo de
razonamiento está limitado  d por el contexto práctico, por
lo que esta es una visión muy progresista
si se compara con la visión tradicional de la
que hablé al principio,
pero aún más conservadora que la que
estoy tratando de desarrollar aquí,
así que otra cosa que creo que debe estar
ahí en la vanguardia de esto.  La propuesta
es que la racionalidad implica agencia y
autonomía porque se puede decir que algo o solo
algo que hace un organismo
es racional,
así que para usar estas, eh, las ideas del
campo autónomo y activista y de
la teoría de cómo los jugadores son
sistemas autónomos como  un Roomba
no puede ser racional porque no es un
agente, no es el autor de su propio
comportamiento, está diseñado por
agentes externos para funcionar de cierta manera, por lo que
no es estrictamente hablando una nación, así que
ahí es donde trazaría la línea de dónde
bueno  no puede no tiene sentido
atribuir racionalidad a un Roomba por
ejemplo
y
para esto
utilizo las nociones de autonomía y
adaptabilidad el DiPaolo y otros
tienes un  También el libro reciente image the
four sensorial model life y ese famoso
artículo del bowl de 2005 donde
habla sobre la adaptabilidad
para establecer sus restricciones muy generales
sobre lo que significa ser ruso,
por lo que los sistemas autónomos se
conciben como redes precarias.
red precaria de procesos porque la
organización y los límites físicos son
producidos por el propio sistema el sistema
mantiene continuamente sus propias
condiciones de viabilidad lo que se
conoce como dar sentido donde el
sistema exploró
las condiciones ambientales ambientales que son
favorables para su automantenimiento y
evita los que le son perjudiciales
así es como entiendo que son
los muy en general que
limitan emocionalmente a un ser racional
que debe ser un sistema autónomo
y lo interesante aquí es que
el concepto de adaptabilidad que Paulo pero
adelante es que la capacidad de un
organismo para mejorar su condición
de autoproducción a través de  h
cambios estructurales internos,
por lo que implica el seguimiento y la
regulación de los cambios internos
para seleccionar el mejor curso de
acción disponible. Creo que es otro
concepto interesante en el que pensar para
incluir esta idea de una
noción radicalmente inactiva de racionalidad que
no está necesariamente comprometido con el
razonamiento y el contenido,
por lo que la agencia se realiza a través del
ejercicio de habilidades situadas que
promueven cambios dentro del organismo de
acuerdo con las restricciones y subestaciones ambientales, lo
que significa que qué tan bien se adapta un organismo
para tratar
con soltura con su entorno es una medida  de o
una indicación de su racionalidad, cuanto
más racional es un organismo, más
adecuado es para tratar con su
entorno y hemos previsto las
circunstancias
y, al hacerlo, el organismo mejora
los intercambios continuos entre sí mismo
y el entorno,
que es crucial para su supervivencia y
es una
forma muy naturalizada de pensar la
racionalidad  es principalmente la capacidad de
mejorar los cambios para la supervivencia,
esta es
la idea general aquí,
así que, como dije antes, ¿qué pasa con el razonamiento
que quiero
? No quiero comprometer la racionalidad
necesariamente con el razonamiento y esto es de
lo que se trata la racionalidad radicalmente inactiva,
pero yo  no quiero excluir el
razonamiento como una combinación racional anterior,
así que lo que digo es
que no está definido por el razonamiento, pero no lo es,
eh, no excluye el
razonamiento, creo que el razonamiento se consideraría como
un modo especial o específico de
agencia racional  uno que es exclusivo de nuestro
conocimiento para los seres humanos,
pero no es la característica definitoria de la
racionalidad,
así que para esto, eh, para explicar
esta idea, recuerdo cómo Hutu y
Saturno entre el papel en el libro más reciente
de utani explican el  surgimiento
de un alto reconocimiento la idea es que
ser capaz de involucrarse en el contenido para la
cognición depende en última instancia de estar
socialmente integrado culturalmente
donde el contenido cognoscitivo completo surgió
de la sociedad  interacción cultural general, de modo que cuando
un individuo participa en
prácticas culturales sociales
, acepta habilidades cognitivas más antiguas
para manejar símbolos y, al
hacerlo, se
encuentra en un largo proceso de enculturación, por
supuesto,
se vuelve capaz de comprometerse con
una coordinación simbólica que no es
interna.  Representación específica
porque está públicamente disponible. No son
representaciones mentales en el sentido tradicional,
pero tiene las características de la
cognición simbólica sin el compromiso con
la representación interna o las representaciones mentales,
por lo que actuar racionalmente en su sentido más general
es la idea de que el
comportamiento competente de un  organismo está en uh es es
el comportamiento competente de un organismo
en su entorno depende de la
coordinación de las habilidades incorporadas
mientras que el razonamiento si todo va
bien, por supuesto, se entiende como contenido
para la racionalidad para mi modo específico de
racionalidad el razonamiento es el
comportamiento competente de un  organismo en un ambiente
cultural social  entorno,
que es un aspecto más específico de nuestro
entorno, por supuesto, y depende de
la coordinación de tal base cultural
o contenido que involucra habilidades
que son más recientes en la
escala filogenética humana,
así que esta es la idea más grande,
esta es la  Creo que
la parte propositiva y aquí están
las objeciones de las que quería hablar. La
primera es que es una
visión muy liberal, es muy
, está bien, abarca demasiado,
se diría porque si la acción racional se
reduce a la coordinación.  de
las habilidades cognitivas entonces la racionalidad es
algo gradual pues un organismo puede
ser más o menos competente en sus
interacciones ambientales
y el rechazo va de acuerdo a la
racionalidad radicalmente inactiva muchos
organismos logran y mantienen un
comportamiento Adaptativo en el nicho con
diferentes niveles de éxito al cual yo
Estoy bien, alguien podría cantar racionalidades racionales
y activas radicales y activas
a Liberal y esto es  una
objeción que escuché en persona
y la guardé con tanta fuerza porque creo
que es muy, es una muy buena manera de
decirlo, incluso las uñas son racionales en
esta vista y eso a lo que debo decir
que estoy dispuesto a comprar  la billetera,
bueno, sí, es más liberal que
los puntos de vista tradicionales, por supuesto, está
destinado a serlo, pero no creo que
este sea un problema per se, lo que creo que es
la parte positiva aquí es que
conserva una diferencia de grado que
son los humanos  mucho más racional que otros
animales simplemente porque somos capaces de
realizar una amplia variedad de acciones en una
amplia variedad de circunstancias dinámicas
que están mucho más allá de cualquier otro animal
que conozcamos,
así que volvamos al ejemplo de este
clavo, este clavo puede  realizar algunas
acciones complejas puede moverse de un punto a
otro, puede buscar comida
y refugio, etc., pero tienen
un conjunto crítico limitado de habilidades
si rodeas este clavo con el sur,
por ejemplo, está condenado a morir por
la réplica y los humanos, por otro
lado, son mucho más adaptables y
capaces de lidiar dinámicamente con muchas
circunstancias imprevistas, así que
mi respuesta a esa objeción es que
sí,
bueno, es muy liberal, pero ese
no es el problema, el problema sería si
eso  es si tuviera espacio para una
diferencia de grado entre cómo los animales se
relacionan con su
entorno y esta es la otra
objeción de objeto que creo que puede ser, aunque
la que más le interesa,
entonces sabe que es el procesamiento predictivo 12
parece implicar inferencias y contenido
todo el tiempo,
pero al principio debo advertirles a ustedes y a
los espectadores que
en el momento en que escribí esto, este documento
era mucho más optimista sobre esta
posibilidad de combinar un activismo y
codificación predictiva o
procesamiento predictivo y uh  Creo que hay
puntos importantes aquí, pero está este
artículo reciente de Olu y Evan Thompson
y Randy Beer donde
brindan una evaluación crítica de uh th
e los intentos de combinar principalmente
el principio de energía libre y
um
teorías inactivas y autobiográficas, por lo que ahora estoy
mayormente convencido por los argumentos, pero
creo que hay algunos puntos interesantes
de comparación aquí, sin embargo, el
proceso predictivo en nuestro
código predictivo y uh en el  Estuve escribiendo
y hasta el día de hoy está de moda en
las ciencias cognitivas
.  estoy hablando
y en estos visores sabes que la
competencia se entiende como un proceso
de minimización de errores que ocurre en
estrechas jerarquías bidireccionales
por lo
que tienes la generación de
modelos internos para la actividad de las capas inferiores
que anticipa las causas distales de los
estímulos siniestros que es un
proceso de arriba hacia abajo y la minimización de la
discrepancia entre la predicción y
la señal de estímulo actual por
um la ocupación de anteriores que  es la
parte inferior del proceso, por
lo que aquí hay, por supuesto, una inferencia activa
que se entiende, por ejemplo,
en términos informales, ya conoces, formales de
Clark de que un organismo mueve sus sensores
de maneras que equivalen a buscar activamente en
nuestra generación generando las
consecuencias sensoriales que son más bien  sus
cerebros esperan que
esta sea una forma de entender la
influencia activa en términos muy formales, pero
creo que hace el trabajo,
así que el cerebro infiere la
fuente esperada de los estímulos recibidos
si parece que hay un
problema con lo que estoy  Hablando
de que la lectura de votación del
procesamiento predictivo, que es la que usa el
sesgo del producto y el derecho de inferencia, dice,
por ejemplo, que el proceso de
percepcionistas es separable del
proceso de sesgo racional más amplio de
prolificación y efectos de arriba hacia abajo del contexto
, sentí que cada
nivel intermedio de  procesar esto me ha llamado la
atención la forma en que Clark también está
hablando de racionalidad todo el tiempo,
pero es un  Un tipo de racionalidad inferencial
y un razonamiento influyente generalizado
parecen implicar contenido impervasivo
y luego el procesamiento predictivo parece
ser incompatible con la racionalidad radicalmente inactiva,
bueno, pero en ese momento
había y creo que todavía podemos argumentar en
varios de los no hay
no.  - hemorroides y lectura de
procesamiento predictivo
que usa, por ejemplo, un primer paso
sería usar un sentido deflacionario de
predicción que comprendía cameo en un
artículo breve de 2013 pero cuarto donde
los valores de dos o más variables
covari o son valor confiablemente por lo que el
el valor de 1 le permite al observador inferir
el valor de otro y aquí la
inferencia está ocurriendo al
nivel de la observación, no en una
variable lejana, está infiriendo el valor de
otra, por lo que la idea sería, creo,
que el contenido está en el ojo de  el
espectador la persona que interpreta cómo
la selección de censura que ponemos se
aproxima a las predicciones internas aquí
entendidas en t  El sentido inflacionario puede
describirlo en términos inferenciales y sesgados
, así es como veo, por ejemplo,
la idea sobre 4 000 del
artículo de Bruno, que si no me equivoco, el
título es algo así como el cerebro no es
un científico y el argumento está en  esta
dirección general
que estamos proyectando cómo los
científicos interpretan la actividad cerebral como una
característica del cerebro mismo como si
estuviera prediciendo e infiriendo este sentido más
robusto o de mayor peso,
entonces lo que estoy tratando de decir aquí es que
la inferencia activa entonces uso doble  y
di doble olvidé el nombre de esto en
inglés lo siento
um no es uh el sentido literal de la
inferencia aquí de acuerdo con la racionalidad radicalmente
inactiva
uh es que desarmado para la
eficiencia del comportamiento coorientado, el
agente tiene que actuar de ciertas
maneras para su  sus estados llegan a
buen término de manera más eficiente y menos costosa,
esto no implica la afirmación más controvertida de
que los modelos generativos
mismos muestran y realizan
inferencias predictivas  es una
lectura muy deflacionaria del
procesamiento predictivo para proporcionar esta
combinación con una racionalidad radical y activa
y aquí hay un comienzo en un artículo de
por modelo, no se sigue que un
organismo tenga un
modelo de representación interno de su nicho en el sentido de
que  es este modelo que esos son el
trabajo cognitivo si te gusta en cambio un
organismo es un modelo que son las
regularidades causales y estadísticas reflejadas en
algún entorno reflejando algún
fenotipo que es un modelo
y bueno
esto se relaciona con algo que recientemente
mi colega notificó y yo  He estado
hablando sobre la idea de cómo los
organismos producen un mundo de acuerdo con un
activismo que es la idea de que el organismo
y el medio ambiente son
históricamente llamados históricamente determinados, por lo que
en la escala genética de flujo esto
podría explicarse a través de la idea de la construcción de nicho,
la idea de que una vez  un
organismo es activo en su entorno
promueve cambios que si son lo
suficientemente estables como para  Pueden ser heredados por su
descendencia y estos cambios proporcionan nuevas
presiones de presión evolutivas
que conducen su camino evolutivo.
Otra descripción también ha explorado una idea similar, esta vez relacionando la
construcción de nichos
y la psicología ecológica,
por lo que mi respuesta a esa objeción es
que actuar racionalmente significa lograr
un compromiso competente con el
entorno a través de la predicción
y su minimización. Estoy dispuesto a
aceptar esa caracterización, pero
los procesos sesgados racionales y más amplios
no tienen por qué implicar contenido para la cognición
si entendemos que en Flash.  la
predicción sin sentido y su minimización
involucran la selección de entrada y la
coordinación de intercapacidades en las
maneras de involucrarse en el mundo, lo cual es
exactamente el principal reclamo de
la personalidad radical y activa, así que creo que en
esa medida el procesamiento predictivo no es más
bien un enemigo.  que una mentira
de esta idea en lugar de uh
llegada pero de c  Por supuesto, hay otros
problemas de compatibilidad que tengo y no los
he tocado aquí, pero eso es
todo lo que he pensado hoy. Gracias.
Genial. Muchas gracias.
escribir cualquier pregunta
reuniré mis notas y comencemos la
discusión
está
bien primero solo gracias de nuevo por la
charla
¿qué tal un poco de contexto sobre cómo
llegó a hacer estas preguntas en
su puesto actual y cómo se desarrollaron sus
intereses en esta área porque
hay  Tantas ideas interesantes y
solo quería aprender más sobre cómo
llegaste a este marco y agudizaste tu
punto,
está bien, gracias, esa es una buena
pregunta porque no es frecuente que
puedas explorar este fondo,
es importante, así que estaba en ese momento.
Creo que estaba escribiendo mi tesis
doctoral, tal vez fue en 2007 o algo así, y
estaba defendiendo la idea de que la
racionalidad debe ser algo que, en
última instancia, está involucrado en el mundo.  hay una
tendencia a pensar bien, incluso entre, como
les dije, como les mostré, entre, eh, en
períodos encarnados con personas de
ciertas, debe ser esencialmente Mundo que
involucra, como la actuación y la práctica,
etc.
y la percepción, por supuesto, pero la racionalidad
permanece.  algo así como una
noción naturalizable algo que no
puede reducirse al nivel del
no podría reducirse de una manera
como la percepción que podría explicarse
por un cierto compromiso dinámico y
así sucesivamente
así que en ese momento estaba pensando eso bien
tal vez este sea
un problema de rodilla porque
en
otros contextos se toma para implicar que,
sea cual sea la percepción, si no se
articula de una manera que proporcione un
cierto ajuste con la combinación profesional,
entonces la percepción es un hecho
y este es el mito de la
Dimensión dada  al principio y pensé
que bueno, tal vez esto
es algo así como un mito de lo
dado trabajando aquí en una
cognición activa pero esto no lo creo  no es
fatal porque no podemos
argumentar en principio que en lugar de
construir la percepción escalonada y
otras formas básicas de combinaciones que
involucran conceptos y similares, tal vez
podríamos argumentar
desde la otra dirección, tratar de
reducir la racionalidad en un nivel más no
naturalizado de
uh
así que esa fue la motivación y fue
muy fue un proceso de revisión largo y
creo que mi primera la primera versión
del documento el espectador fue muy
creo que tenían toda la razón yo
Respaldé la sugerencia después de todo pero él
fue muy eh
ellos  fueron muy firmes en tomar esa
parte y creo que fue para mejor
porque es otra literatura
es otra, uh, muchas referencias que
generalmente no están en conversación con un
activismo y reconocimiento corporal y fue
muy difícil simplemente poner el  asunto en
los mismos términos para avanzar en mis argumentos,
así que es algo que taché
y no he pensado demasiado en
ese sistema, pero creo que es algo que me
gustaría  para volver y tal vez,
incluso probablemente, alguien lo haya hecho en los
últimos años, no estoy consciente,
puedo recordar, pero
esta relación entre un activismo, el
mito del regalo y parecía ser,
parece ser muy
obvio.  Entonces, creo que es algo que
podríamos, deberíamos, quiero decir, eh, ser capaces de
explorar, pero no hay algo que
estuviera en el frente del documento,
pero tuve esta idea de hablar sobre la
racionalidad en todos los sentidos
y al mismo tiempo.  tiempo estuve leyendo mucho
sobre uh
lo llamé desde una
perspectiva filosófica, por supuesto, como dije, no soy
muy versado en los tecnicismos
y las formalidades del enfoque,
pero estaba interesado en las
consecuencias filosóficas allí y
pensé bien  tal vez haya algo para
comparar aquí porque, como muestra la cita de Clark,
puedes hablar sobre la racionalidad todo el
tiempo y eso es algo que
quería desarrollar, pero no en una visión cognitivista, pero no en una
película radicalmente encarnada, así que
ese es el trasfondo
genial gracias podrías tal vez
describir cuál es el mito de lo
dado cuál fue el contexto en el que
surgió ese mito y hacia dónde vamos después
de mencionar el mito de lo dado
porque lo vi como un concepto que
entretejiste, entonces, ¿de qué se trataba? Está
bien, en medio de darlo,
bueno, hay varios datos posibles
dependiendo de tu sabor de filosofía
mía, pero más clásicamente en
campos anteriores de la Mente, toma el
contenido de la percepción para ser dado.  oración
racionalmente de una manera que tenemos ciertas
entradas que son simplemente recibidas por la
mente y la mente las interpreta para que los
vendedores diferentes vendedores sean famosos por
haber descrito su eh este problema como
un problema no solo para aumentar los combustibles
de la mente sino también  para los racionalistas,
pero por otro lado, lo racional
generalmente se toma como una intuición racional, lo
que quiere decir que hay
algún nivel de cognición que no está
articulado.  es dado o como algunas
personas hablan de ser criado dado,
pero de alguna manera existe este nivel de
cognición que se da y la mente tiene
que interpretarlo, pero si se da de
esta manera, no tiene punto de contacto, no
hay intersección entre lo que sea.
haga lo que haga la mente y este
nivel básico de dominación, así que mi idea es
evitar la acusación de estar comprometido
con el mito de lo dado, pero nuevamente,
esto no es algo explícito en
la literatura nativista, pero es
algo que parece ser  es
posible desarrollar en un
quiero decir uh en este tipo de comparación,
pero no es no desde el
no claramente allí, sino
una forma de resolverlos para que los
Givens digan que el contenido perceptivo
ya es de naturaleza conceptual, que es,
por ejemplo, cómo Joe McDowell  ¿
Tienes en cuenta cuanto más sabes una
percepción? El chiste viene con
subtítulos e interpretas el mundo
como lo haces, pero
creo que de una forma u otra es
para desmitificar que conoces una racionalidad.  y
las capas superiores de combinación
intentan pensar en ellas uh uh en menos
uh contenido para el análisis
sin comprometerlas, por lo que es estrictamente
hablando con un nivel de contenido que está
divorciado de los niveles básicos de
combinación, esa es una forma en que pienso
hacerlo y  la racionalidad parece ser el
único concepto clave para hacer esto
porque generalmente se asume que todo es algo
exclusivamente humano y algo que está
relacionado con el razonamiento y bueno, si es
así, entonces la racionalidad no puede informar la acción
y, por supuesto, si la acción es
de naturaleza sin contenido.  entonces, si la racionalidad
es un sentido esencialmente lleno de contenido y la
reacción es esencialmente incontenible por
carecer de contenido, entonces puedes no tener
esto,
eh, eso ha hecho esta eh intersección
entre dos dominios y esto es
algo que quería evitar, pero como
te dije, se volvió tan difícil de  expresar
estos puntos de vista de manera
suficientemente clara y general es
que, por recomendación de nuestro revisor,
elimino eso y
sigo pensando en  Pero nada.
No he desarrollado una
línea de argumentación adecuada que lo aborde con
más claridad de lo que puedo hacer, como acabo de hacer,
en términos muy generales.
como la relación de la racionalidad y la
aptitud
como una función biológica cierto sí sí
está bien yo um
creo que es una
relación intrínseca realmente creo que es
uh probablemente la más
[Música]
um
consecuencia obvia de la acción racional
en una escala especial y cuando  hablamos
sobre si la racionalidad es una característica
de ciertas especies o en lugar de
individuos. Creo que la aptitud es uno de
los
conceptos clave aquí para pensar que
esto es el resultado de esta
acción racional,
aunque no digo que no lo haga.
ponlo en esos asuntos en el papel
creo que es posible pensarlo de esa
manera no lo ves
como una objeción para pensar en la
racionalidad pero de nuevo es muy liberal
y estoy dispuesto a t  o aceptar esta
consecuencia también, cada
organismo vivo de alguna manera si aún no ha
pasado Instinct, por lo que se adapta de alguna manera
a su entorno, por lo que estoy dispuesto
a ver que puede implicar un
nivel mínimo de racionalidad de  lidiando con
el entorno cambiante del enemigo,
pero bueno, y es el precio de tener una
noción progresista muy liberal de las
racionalidades, creo que esto es una consecuencia
de eso,
así que has dicho que la aptitud es una
consecuencia del comportamiento racional, ¿
hay otras consecuencias o  ¿Cómo
reconocemos la racionalidad desde el exterior,
además de decir bien, la
colonia de hormigas está prosperando en la medida en
que es racional, es adaptativa, una
agencia de exhibición y todo eso,
um, es un
concepto de racionalidad tan deflacionario que todas las
cosas existentes, humanos y  de lo contrario, simplemente se
describen por él o hay algunos
resultados que podemos usar para desenredar,
como por ejemplo, un comportamiento racional o
irracional, de simplemente las
consecuencias reflejadas por su  rvival y
Fitness
bien, tuve que pensar con mucho
cuidado sobre esto porque no
quiero trivializar este concepto de una manera
que bueno, todo es IPS de hecho o
racional por el hecho de que está
viviendo está actuando relación pero yo
Creo que, en casos particulares, uno
podría identificar a la nación que soy
igual a los individuos,
um, autosuficiencia en ese nicho, tan
a nivel individual en particular,
está bien, esta es una
acción concluyente que podría clasificarse como
irracional en la medida en que  uh
son perjudiciales para con la supervivencia pero
uh a nivel de especie es más
difícil argumentar de esa manera
porque identificar este tipo de comportamiento o
consecuencia pero creo que
para no trivializar la idea de
racional y decir bien todo lo que es
vivir es factorizado, tendrías que
identificar este tipo de actos particulares
que van en detrimento
de una supervivencia,
por lo que en el caso de la colonia de hormigas
, no sé, tal vez
Dar la bienvenida a los invasores sería un
tipo de comportamiento que
sería perjudicial para la
supervivencia como tal
. No sé, no sé si esto es
eh, es una forma imposible de
pensar en esto.
cuidadosamente,
oh, muy interesante, y lo introdujiste
en esa respuesta y en la presentación
como múltiples
escalas de tiempo anidadas, tal como lo hace Eco Evo
Devo desde una perspectiva más biológica
, observando cómo la
construcción de nichos cierra la brecha entre
los procesos filogenéticos más lentos y los procesos de
desarrollo más rápidos,
um tan  ¿Cómo se relaciona esta
consideración incrustada y de múltiples escalas
con el
concepto de contenido, como si el contenido se
localizará en un cuerpo o si el contenido se
distribuirá entre entidades o si la
racionalidad se distribuirá entre entidades?
¿Cómo identificaríamos el lugar
de la racionalidad y eso?  también
invoca la concepción um horizontal y modular
de la cita que
proporcionó, entonces, ¿cómo identificamos lo sobresaliente?
escalas temporales espaciales y sistemas de
interés
oh ah no sé, no sé si puedo
responder uh esto completamente, pero me parece
que al nivel de uh si estamos hablando
de contenido, por ejemplo, contenido como una
precisión  condiciones para los
pensamientos simbólicos Creo que, afortunadamente, tenemos que
decir que no está localizado en un
solo individuo, se comparte públicamente,
por lo que puede decir que,
um,
una consecuencia de esto es que es
posible pensar en diferentes
patrones de razonamiento que han
sido
sitios de información.  en diferentes momentos, etc., y puede
ver que desarrollaron diferentes
reglas de nivel diferente para la
información de contenido
y creo que es
plausible decir que el contenido
está localizado que el
eh, ¿cómo puede decir que comparte la cantidad
que conoce los detalles de
solo por racionalidad, creo que
uno podría
[Música]
identificar en comportamientos particulares
si se ajusta a estos, eh,
este tipo de descripción de, eh, giro
competente, interacción competente y
adaptativo.  la interacción entre un organismo
y su entorno es su nicho, por lo que
probablemente
podríamos dar diferentes respuestas aquí
como racionalidad y contenido. Estoy dispuesto
a decir que el
contenido para la organización no es
algo que sucede en la cabeza,
algo que está ahí afuera de una manera
compartida.  la cantidad de otros y esto es
algo que mi filosofía
tiene al menos desde los años 60,
mis filósofos han
defendido la idea de que el contenido está individualizado externamente
y, eh, creo que este es uno de
los videos de  por ejemplo, Hillary Putnam
y Tyler Burge y otros, que el
contenido mental se individualiza a
nivel comunitario o social pero,
por otro lado, piensan que la
racionalidad podría
individualizarse en principio en comportamientos particulares,
pero dependería de las metas del individuo
y el  el nicho que habita y
así
sucesivamente, por supuesto,
aquí hay variables reales que también podrían ser importantes
para identificar el
comportamiento  como racional o no
está bien,
gracias,
bueno, una frase que realmente
me quedó grabada fue saber cómo, no saber,
tal vez un punto básico en tu trabajo
y un enfoque en esa acción, así que solo
quería
saber cómo la acción y la práctica a medida
que tejiste.  ellos aquí hoy cómo se
abordan esos términos
y cómo son las cosas diferentes hoy en día con
el tratamiento de la acción y la práctica y el
saber hacer no sé que decir en el
helmholtzee en días o incluso en las
tradiciones antiguas o en el conocimiento mundial
Así que bien, genial, entonces la idea  Creo que
sería que,
um,
hay una tendencia de, eh, es una
tendencia de una filosofía muy moderna,
pero ha sido muy influyente en la
primera ola de la ciencia cognitiva pensar
en la percepción como
una capacidad para categorizar el entorno
y ofrecer un discreto  descripción de
los aspectos ambientales, por ejemplo,
percibir
que sé que la taza está a mi izquierda es
una cuestión de saber que hay
algo que busca tales propiedades para
mi izquierda y esto es una especie de, bueno,
una especie de actitud proposicional
hacia el mundo, así
que creo que
lo interesante del activismo y
la psicología ecológica también y en la
medida en que recuerdan el
pragmatismo estadounidense desde el comienzo de  el
siglo es pensar en la
percepción no como una cuestión de
categorizar estas grandes propiedades en
el mundo sino como revelar
posibilidades para actuar
y esto es algo que si tuviéramos que
explicar eso en términos de eh en
términos epidémicos como el conocimiento, lo haríamos.  No lo
pongo como una cuestión de saber que la
curva está a mi izquierda pero saber
agarrar la taza y hacer lo que quiera
hacer con ella si quiero tomar una taza de
café o si quiero usarla como un
pisapapeles tendrá diferentes
propiedades silenciosas y esto es algo
que,
aunque ha sido, creo,
muy creo que un activismo y la
psicología ecológica y otras visiones incorporadas de la
cognición han tenido un gran éxito
en el cambio.  Llevando esta discusión a este
punto, creo que en las
ciencias cognitivas más tradicionales todavía
tienes la idea de que los
organismos se perciben bien al
describir la forma en que el
entorno es algo que creo que
las lecturas más tradicionales del
procesamiento predictivo dejan claro.
como en uh la idea de que estás infiriendo
sobre la fuente de los estímulos y no
en uh y no y esto no es Quiero decir que
esto es más fácilmente compatible con la idea de
que el cerebro o el
sistema cognitivo sabe que
el mundo es  así y así
el medio ambiente es así y así en lugar de
decir que el sistema de agenda sabe
cómo interactuar con el mundo y creo que
el punto que los
activistas y los psicólogos ecológicos
están tratando de hacer es
y también trabajar en el predictivo
la codificación y el principio de energía libre,
etc., es mostrar que estas nociones, estos
marcos, podrían ser una idea mínima de que
el sistema
kubernetes sabe cómo participar, sabe cómo participar.  ge en el
medio ambiente de una manera que no necesita
leerse dentro del resumen de
que el sistema Kindle está infiriendo
que el mundo es así, así que creo que esta es
una forma de explicar pero también
filosóficamente si tienes un gran
al principio de  las últimas
décadas, eh, una discusión gigantesca sobre
si ninguna Nube podría reducirse para
saber eso y, de nuevo, tienes un
trasfondo de esto y otro
como una noción independiente de sabes
eso y si podrías
reducir uno a otro y así sucesivamente  así
que creo que no se detiene allí, no puede,
eh, aunque puedo hacer un reclamo por la
percepción de que otros saben
que todavía son el problema
de fondo de si el conocimiento podría tratarse como
y todo eso de todos
modos esto es algo que  También estoy
trabajando recientemente,
hay mucho que decir,
es una idea muy interesante, especialmente con
la comunicación lingüística, es un
poco como el dedo y la luna y
hablar sobre la luna, pero el dedo es
solo  dónde está y no estamos
hablando del puntero, estamos hablando de
la referencia
y, por lo tanto, usar
una forma de comunicación sociocognitiva
en un lenguaje culto
o en un discurso académico escrito para mirar a
través de eso o reimaginarlo y
ver incluso lo que parece  ser como el
pináculo de saber eso
y aún verlo como saber cómo
supongo que la pregunta es
cómo leemos los periódicos
sí, por supuesto, sí, creo que es eh, es
un
eh, sí, los valores parecen
poder ser  un problema muy grande porque si
tratamos de tratar estas
capacidades negativas como mencionaste como una cuestión
de saber
hacer, parece que todavía nos falta algo
sobre la comunicación, por ejemplo, y
por otro lado creo y esta es mi
intuición, pero creo  que en
principio podríamos hablar de
que
entender lo que acabas de decir y
tratar de responder es cuestión de
saber comportarse lingüísticamente
pero creo que incluso este movimiento
para tratar altos niveles de
cognición me hizo  t una cuestión de conocimientos técnicos
todavía deja algo fuera
Estoy en lo que quiero decir personalmente
estoy satisfecho con eso Creo que en algún
nivel tenemos que decir que bueno, ese es
otro tipo de enfoque que se necesita
aquí para explicar cómo  comunicarse, por
ejemplo, de manera
muy adecuada, por no decir que
no implica y ahora, pero no es solo
que creo que al menos
se necesita más que conocimiento práctico,
pero tal vez la clave aquí es pensar en
conocimiento práctico solo básico y
necesario para otros tipos  de otros otros
tipos de conocimiento que se necesitan
para participar en este tipo de intercambio
tal vez tal vez esta sea una capa
al menos mi posición actual es que, de
ninguna manera, proporciona la base de nuestro
compromiso con el mundo y con los
demás, pero en algún momento tenemos
que ser capaces de desarrollar otros tipos de
comprensión para explicar y explicar
los tipos complejos de eh  intercambios que
tenemos en nuestra vida diaria
, como leer documentos, como dijiste
. Estoy de acuerdo. Creo que
enmarcar saber eso como base y luego
recuperar saber cómo es un desafío
y también es un desafío comenzar con los
procesos cognitivos básicos como si estuvieran
representados en ninguna casa y  volver a ensamblar esas
piezas de conocimiento para saber que, de
nuevo, no es necesariamente un
desafío simple, sino que preferiríamos enfrentar
el desafío de ensamblar procesos cognitivos simbólicos
proposicionales declarativos verbales
Etc desde un
enfoque cognitivo ecológico más liminal
o tratar de recuperar lo ecológico de
lo turing  máquina en cierto sentido, por lo
que parece
que está hablando en apoyo de la conexión
a tierra en procesos cognitivos basales plausibles ecológicos
y luego trabaja para
ensamblar el rascacielos
sí sí sí totalmente sí creo que está
bien que
ambos enfoques sean difíciles
de ensamblar  como dijiste para proporcionar
este tipo de explicación, ya sea de
abajo a la izquierda o de arriba hacia abajo, pero yo  Soy más
favorable, por supuesto, al enfoque web
. Creo que también por otra
razón, parece que el punto de
partida parece ser
una descripción biológica de cómo
interactuamos con el mundo y, al
revés, parece ser mucho más
difícil.  para explicar uh cómo llegamos
a estas uh preguntas biológicas
como la morfología de nuestro cuerpo y parece
que primero tenemos que dar cuenta de eso
y luego llegamos a las otras
preguntas que también son difíciles de
responder pero al mismo tiempo  al menos creo
que es
un enfoque de abajo hacia arriba es más uh
integrador en cierto modo es que lo más probable
es que parece ser más
uh a nuestro favor en el sentido
y la forma en que
lo enmarcaste me hizo pensar que si fueras  para
programar una computadora desde
cero, podría ser una computadora abstracta o virtual
, por lo que ni siquiera necesita tener
una realización específica
y, en esa situación, uno podría estar
preocupado por ensamblar
saber que afirmar eso y ensamblar
estas declaraciones
declaraciones originales y procesos lógicos en
algo que es más dinámico o que
interactúa con el entorno, sin embargo,
ese proceso de ingeniería de pila completa
con lógica y silicona en la base
es bastante diferente de cómo llegamos aquí
, por lo que podría ser, pero es
complementario,
bueno.  diste un poco de visibilidad,
eh, supongo que el antes, durante y
después de la revisión por pares, así que tenía
curiosidad por saber qué
cambió durante y después del artículo, como
en los últimos meses o años o el
tiempo que duró, cómo evolucionaste en esto
y luego qué  ¿Cree que los próximos pasos son relevantes,
ya sean para usted o
simplemente generales? ¿
Estamos buscando una medición del cerebro? ¿
Buscamos una cámara de video en un bosque?
¿Buscamos un avance conceptual?
sus
desarrollos
, esa es una gran pregunta, creo,
um
, no estoy completamente satisfecho con la
forma en que usaré el nivel extranjero, no
sé si esto se llevará a
cabo.  t en eh, honestamente, no sé
si podría, en principio, llevarse a cabo en
otros términos empíricos, pero
eh, no estoy diciendo que, eh, bueno,
uno es que lo escribiría un poco
diferente hoy, no es que no sea, eh, no es que no esté de
acuerdo con el  papel
originalmente pero creo que
hay algo algunos puntos que me
gustaría replantear pero no
autorizan eh tampoco creo que tenía un nuevo
papel
pero tal vez en el futuro pero esto es
algo que
han dado las preguntas como el mito
que es  Todavía la pregunta filosófica
y conceptual todavía me molestan
, pero todavía tengo
que encontrar la oportunidad de desarrollar estas
ideas con más cuidado y la
visión general que expuse allí
.  Todavía estoy esperando
esta oportunidad para elaborarla más y
ver hasta dónde puedo llegar, pero aún no lo
sé. Debo admitir que no sé cuáles son
los desarrollos futuros de esta idea,
pero he estado trabajando.  en varios
temas aislados  s en este enfoque
durante los últimos años he trabajado con
la noción de información y
comprensión científica e información para
activistas ecológicos y de
combinación y recientemente estoy trabajando
más recientemente con algunas universidades en
realidad virtual y
reconocimiento de percepción así que
esto  es como me gusta llevar a cabo mi
investigación para
encontrar preguntas interesantes y ver cómo puedo lidiar
con ellas, pero no necesariamente
me
encuentro atado a una
sola línea de razonamiento de esa manera, así que esto
es lo que sucedió en el momento en que estaba
trabajando con  racionalidad si pensara que
era un tema muy interesante y todavía
creo que lo es, pero no he tenido tiempo
de volver y replantear lo que quería,
pero tal vez tal vez en
un futuro cercano, no lo sé, pero más  lo
más reciente en lo que he estado trabajando
no está relacionado con la racionalidad celular,
pero creo que algunos productos
podrían estar equivocados, como el de una
realidad virtual y
cómo se compara la realidad visual con la realidad
virtual.  combinación porque
bueno, obviamente hay algo que falta
en la perseverancia y el
entorno visual,
por supuesto, si alguien, por
ejemplo, si estoy en un
entorno visual en el que estoy bajo una especie de
amenaza, puedo sentir algo parecido al
miedo, pero  Realmente no estoy temiendo por mi
vida
e imagino que la persona en la
realidad virtual es racional
huir de
la amenaza la amenaza virtual y
así sucesivamente esto es esto esto es
lo que estoy haciendo  en y tal vez es que
proporciona un punto de retorno a
esta idea de la racionalidad radical y activa
y, de hecho, el artículo
acaba de ser aceptado, así que, como les
decía antes, estuve muy ocupado estos últimos
días porque estábamos corrigiendo las pruebas.
colegas y yo nunca figurativo
eh y yo también
tenía una agenda apretada
para enviar la versión corregida del
artículo en las últimas semanas y luego
obtuve las pruebas y
oh
uh bueno tal vez uh en el futuro pueda
volver a la iss  debido a la racionalidad
me gustaría pero no sé si
no sé realmente no puedo prever los
desarrollos de eso pero en general
todavía estoy de acuerdo con mi idea original pero la
enmarcaré un poco diferente  Un poco,
el punto de realidad virtual, estoy seguro de que hay
mucho más que decir allí, pero me recordó
solo el título de realidad virtual, es una
virtualización y, de la misma manera,
la planificación de acción cognitiva
nos permite entretener
políticas que nuestro cuerpo no  No lo
tomo solo para evaluarlos y elegir en
contra de ellos, pero podemos hacer un vuelo
de fantasía, tener mentalmente un
proceso de selección de políticas caprichosas
de contrafactuales,
pero nuestra morfología es como
nuestra línea de vida, sabes, si realmente te
caes de una cornisa, entonces es  va a doler
y luego, en la realidad virtual, la
experiencia perceptual encarnada es, literalmente,
una virtualización de
situaciones críticas de supervivencia, por lo que
puede verse a sí mismo como si estuviera en una repisa,
pero está en un piso plano
y luego en esa situación
si eres una especie de,
um, un observador cognitivo fuera del
videojuego, podrías decir, bueno, es
racional para mí simplemente caerme para ver
qué
sucede, pero luego hay una capa
de racionalidad dentro del espacio, sí, como
qué es un buen movimiento.  en el juego,
um, y por lo tanto, está desdibujando la línea
entre
[Música
], está desdibujando la criticidad
del cuerpo y, um
, estoy seguro de que has pensado mucho
más en esto, así que, ¿cómo juega esto en nuestra
realidad virtual,
um con el  formas en que pensamos, usamos
y diseñamos estos sistemas,
bueno, estas son las
preguntas que nos motivaron a escribir un
artículo y NADA las dio y yo era
que en la literatura técnica se ve
que muchos investigadores trabajan con
el  trata la percepción visual como
ilustrativa, una especie de ilusión, pero eso nos
molestó un poco porque, por
otro lado, solo funciona en la realidad virtual
porque incorporamos los dispositivos que
funcionan para nosotros. Tienes los controladores.
Tienes la cabeza.
y parece tan extraño decir que
el usuario está bajo una especie de
ilusión
y, por otro lado, parece que en
realidad no es cognición porque, como
dijiste, no hay relevancia biológica
para esos uh cognitivos
Estados, por así decirlo, por ejemplo, si veo
una manzana en la realidad virtual, es que no proporciona
alimento, pero tiene sentido dentro del
juego, ¿verdad?
es algo que puedo comer
pero no en VR puedo fingir, así que
acuñamos este concepto de alusión a
su plano,
eh, es como si estuviéramos
frente a un animal real, pero también implica
esta voluntad de jugar, esta idea de
que no somos
siendo engañados porque nos ponemos el
equipo, sabemos que estamos en el juego y
creo que este es un tema candente en este momento
porque hay metáforas y soy muy
escéptico de todo lo
que pueda la gente es muy optimista pero
sobre las posibilidades del metave  rse
y algunos autores realmente piensan que
podríamos estar en una simulación
estrictamente hablando, pero me refiero a que la mejor
tecnología que nos muestra la tecnología actual
es que es muy limitada y puedes
pretender estar en un entorno determinado
y así sucesivamente y esto creo  puede
ofrecer nuevas formas de
pensar sobre la racionalidad en este
entorno visual de manera que tal vez los
rusos hagan algo que el entorno
ha dicho para saltar de la cornisa y ver
qué sucede y, por otro lado
, los aspectos conductuales de hacerlo a veces la
gente realmente siente  el miedo y la
gente sale a la calle por fobias con las realidades virtuales
y,
um, hay muchas
preguntas interesantes que
tal vez me refiero a futuras investigaciones, podemos,
sí, volver a eso, me hizo pensar en
cómo Apple en la vida real es  podrían ser
calorías para ti pero también podrían ser
calorías para una mosca podría ser arrojada
podrías usarla como un martillo podrías
pintarla bien para que la
ecología y el generativo  proceso, como
diríamos, una especie de inferencia activa
siempre va Más allá de
las posibilidades que se programaron
para un objeto determinado y luego,
um, el discurso actual sobre la realidad virtual se centra en
gran medida en los auriculares,
solo hablando de manera totalmente anecdótica,
no es mi área de
experiencia, um parece un  un poco
interesante es como si la discusión sobre el teléfono móvil
solo se centrara en
rectángulos de cierto tamaño
lo que hace que esto no sea una realidad virtual es
como mirar a través de una ventana y
hay otro compañero con quien hablar así
que no está pegado a mi cabeza no
tenemos algunas de las
capacidades de seguimiento de movimiento que tienen algunas tecnologías
, pero es
una modificación de nicho en el espacio personal de Perry
y podemos enviar
señales y posibilidades entre nosotros
para tener un marco de realidad virtual o realmente solo un
marco de racionalidad y percepción
cognición Acción Ciclos
que
no solo están limitados a una
realización específica o tipo de hardware y pueden
abarcar toda la gama desde Total persona sin conexión
en un campo
hasta s  Alguien que está muy
en The Matrix
parece bastante relevante, de lo contrario, las nuevas
tecnologías, incluso las pequeñas variantes y
las actualizaciones de software, seguirán
sorprendiendo y confundiendo infinitamente.
Sí, creo que es difícil
definir los límites.
Quiero decir que estamos aquí en un intercambio
que  Creo que podría aumentar, pero
clasificarse como una forma de realidad virtual,
por supuesto, veo que arruinas tu mente C,
pero
eh, quiero decir, la mayoría creo que funciona,
hoy en día lo encuentran un documento
diciendo que bueno debe tener un auricular  y a
veces un controlador, pero aparte
de eso, suena a realidad virtual, pero
sí, es difícil definir cualquier cosa,
eh, no lo es, no es un basurero y es
sencillo, esa es una de las cosas
porque hablando comercialmente, por
supuesto, la realidad virtual significa auriculares
y otra parafernalia, pero pero  un
teléfono simplemente hablando por teléfono o un
telégrafo en ese momento habría
estado en esa interfaz con esa
modalidad sensorial y con esas posibilidades
es  la virtualización,
sí, a la que tenemos acceso, es solo un
capítulo diferente hoy,
sí, creo que sí, sí, parte de nuestro artículo
era argumentar que, de alguna manera, la incorporación de
dispositivos tecnológicos obviamente
tiene la necesidad, no, eso no es nuevo, es la
marca de Ser
Humano, es  incorporando dispositivos tecnológicos
lo que nos convirtió en lo que somos desde el
principio usando tecnología analítica y
el hecho de que podemos incorporarlo tan
hábilmente como un dispositivo, incluso si está
programado para, por ejemplo, dentro de
la realidad virtual, tener algo con lo que una
criatura con la que nos controlas mejor.  nueva
morfología otra morfología, por
ejemplo, incluso si ese es el caso, solo
sucede con tanta destreza porque
podemos incorporar el dispositivo. algunos
experimentos han demostrado que puede asignar,
por ejemplo, un giro de su muñeca a un
tercer brazo,
eh, esa realidad individual va
que de tu pecho y la gente puede
aprender a controlar este tercer brazo que
no se mapea en nuestra morfología real
pero puede ser hecho por un Twist o  en la
muñeca,
esto es algo que discutiremos en
nuestro artículo, bueno,
solo puedes hacerlo porque encarnas
el dispositivo, puedes ver que es una
ilusión, en realidad es bueno,
parte de lo que es ser humano es
bordar dispositivos tecnológicos, así que
yo  iría de esa manera Quiero decir, sé que
difumina la distinción entre
brotes virtuales y no virtuales. Creo que esa es una
forma de lidiar con esto.
¿Hay algo más de lo que quieras
hablar?  Me gustaría agradecerle por la
oportunidad de discutir este documento. Fue
muy agradable para mí. Realmente lo disfruté
y este es un ambiente muy agradable y
cómodo para discutir estos
temas y pensar. Gracias una vez más.
estaremos encantados de volver a
hablar con usted en cualquier momento, de
acuerdo, gracias, adiós, gracias.